anyway how are you guys doing how are
you guys doing it's been a long week
re-acclimated to japan yet
yeah i have um
and not to the weather
define re-acclimate
redefine that word
[Music]
i think it was leaving japan that was
much harder because i didn't have a
bidet now i have a bidet so now it feels
like that's good it feels like all the
chaos in the world is
gone and i've returned finally back to
our first world cup yeah yeah yeah it's
like the little things that sometimes
you just like you build up a habit and
then you remember that
you move countries and that habit isn't
the same everywhere like for me it's
gotten it's weird now after how much
we've complained about it now coming
back to japan i'm like oh i have to
bring a mask everywhere again
that's that's something that i've had to
re-acclimate to being in japanese i wish
i i wish we didn't have to re-acclimate
talk as jesus christ wearing a mask
already sucks for someone who has facial
hair and now that plus the 97 humidity
like yeah every time i take my mask off
my face is just wet yeah i got like i
have [ __ ] rabies or something it's
just like salivating well i think i
don't know who said that i might have
been the government i kept making [ __ ]
up
you can yeah you could you can you don't
have to wear masks outside yeah yeah so
it's too damn hot yeah technically yeah
so the japanese government really when
was that like back in like june i think
like the start of the rainy season the
japanese government was like yeah so
this summer's gonna get pretty [ __ ]
excruciating so uh as long as you're not
in a confined space you can and we allow
the japanese government
we'll allow it for you to get to take
your mask off just so you guys you know
won't have to suffer yeah and uh
japanese people are like oh good
permission yeah but now they just like
they don't do it they don't who's the
problem
but that's because i have facial hair
and it makes it like a moist shower and
i'm like i'm not [ __ ] doing this but
now it's like even though the japanese
government was like you guys can take
don't worry you guys can take your mask
they're like all right
yeah yeah
no one again you got to do it
no one does it and everyone has just
like if you have facial hair you just
have [ __ ] swamp chin the entire time
you know and it was so weird because i
remember
flying out of japan i remember going to
the uk and being like man it feels naked
without my mask on yeah it feels wrong
yeah yeah it did it did it
after two years of covert it actually
just felt like you had nothing on
yeah because it just felt so
uncomfortable and then it took like i'm
wearing nothing at all yes it's like
wearing nothing at all but like after
about like i think it was like two weeks
or something i was like oh this is this
is i can breathe i forgot life used to
be forgot this feeling of just being
able to breathe and coming back to japan
and even now just like finding out that
the government allows people to not wear
masks no one has the balls to not do it
anymore even like ubereats drivers
wearing like five layers for some reason
they're still wearing mess while they're
cycling yeah this is like i i saw dude
giant ass who breeds backpack like like
comically large yeah i don't know what
people were ordering massive amounts and
then he was wearing like a full-on like
jeans uh
a t-shirt and then a coat over it
while delivering with a mascot i don't
and i was like what the [ __ ] is
happening i don't understand how people
survive the winter here like if you have
to [ __ ] double up in this heat like
what do you like below 10 degrees
no no like how do you survive the winter
yeah
in the summer
like the goku drip jacket yeah on
ironically like
yeah yeah i see everyone like i think i
feel really weird because i'm the only
one in my [ __ ] train station wearing
shorts yeah yeah yeah i'm like am i am i
am i the slot for showing my knees like
they just they just prioritize drip over
everything yeah they're like that but
it's not even drip because everyone
dresses the same is that that's how drip
mindset is yeah drip is being the same
as everyone else yeah i'm sure for sure
so because like because i don't think
they've figured out how to wear shorts
because
um because i think like wearing shorts
for them is like anti-drip and you can't
have anti-drip on you need to have like
the base level of drip on to that you do
not see people wearing shorts yeah it's
so rare and i feel really weird for
being the only one wearing shorts and
i'm just like but because like i
physically can't i don't know maybe are
they afraid of shin hair or something
like
like what like what
they don't know what is that they don't
see your
except for sku girls in the winter where
it could be like minus 20 and they
somehow just wear short skirts without
any like stockings or leggings or
anything like that exactly yeah i don't
get it there are two types of people
there are two types of drip yeah it's a
drip to wear short things in the winter
is that how it works you can never look
like amazing unless you're like a calvin
klein model wearing shorts you just look
you just look like you're scuffed i
think
i thought you know there's no way of
looking good in shorts if you're like
your body is a normal body that's true
that's true
you know you know you just don't you
look less attractive than wearing pants
yeah yeah i i agree like it's it's also
that you can't look good in shorts but
it's only one outfit you know and you
have to somehow
like stretch this one outfit for the
entire season of summer
i just i just thought about the guy who
did the the thingy pose and you know how
to do it
he's going to drink he can work yeah
he's got the right shirt on you need a
nice like a button down to compliment
the shorts but i just don't i'm wrong
that's why i'm always wearing button
downs dude like look you know i i am a
man of drip myself but sometimes you
know what if i have to prioritize
between drip and my balls being as hot
as an active volcano then i'm i'm gonna
i'm gonna prioritize the shorts yeah
your price comfort because for me i i
try to you know keep aware about what i
wear most the time so i look decent but
for some reason when i wear shorts all
of that goes out the window yeah i'm
like i don't care how i look i'm looking
for like some nice breeze where i need
[ __ ] breeze on my legs i don't care
how i look i look i probably look like a
[ __ ] clown i don't know why yeah i'm
i'm wearing yeah joey's the only one
wearing shorts i'm dreaming
i don't know how the [ __ ] you guys are
it's not that hard okay here's the strat
right so when i go outside i go outside
for one second get inside to go on to
get transport to then come here and then
i'm outside for one more second then i'm
back inside with ac yeah that's probably
yeah it's like a yeah it is
yeah it's like a navy seals operation if
i know exactly where i'm going i know
where all like i know where the cool
spots are i know what i know i try to
minimize the amount of time in the
direct sunlight and direct heat as much
as possible it's like going from one
air-conditioned spot to the other
sure well it's like yeah no but you are
right about the whole thing of like
unless you're a [ __ ] supermodel no
one looks good in shorts because i don't
know why for some reason
ugly every time i wear shorts i feel
like a 14 year old child yeah i don't
understand why it is it's like you know
even if i might be wearing like a really
nice shirt and it's like you know my
hair is nice today or whatever and i
feel like i'm looking good the moment i
look anywhere below and i just see my
bare knees i'm just like why do i look
like a child
and i hate it because i love shorts
they're so comfortable they are i'm like
why why are my legs so [ __ ] ugly you
know like why are my bare legs so ugly
why like it is i was like damn did i
have this much hair on my shins like by
default legs are the ugliest part of the
male body unless you do work out like a
[ __ ] yeah yeah like they just look like
like skeletal or like chubby it's just
like it just looks weird i don't know
because another thing you have to be
aware of is like the length of your sock
as well because there's nothing that
looks more awkward than someone wearing
really short shorts and then they just
forgot that they had really long socks
on so it just it just looks unnatural
right that's where that's where the
struggle comes in because i've replaced
almost all my socks with the family mart
long socks
so like i either have to like push the
long socks down towards my ankle
yeah or i just have to borrow aki's like
short socks which i'm currently doing
right now yeah and also the type of
shoes they're not too small
oh they just they do look quite girly
yeah
but because they are they're good it
works
i uh i should honestly replace all my
i've got a problem now where i've slowly
replaced socks and boxes
over the course of like two three years
so now i've got a bunch of mismatching
boxes and socks where like mismatching
mismatching boxes how do you mismatch
boxes well if you're in an ideal world
every single pair of boxes i own would
look the same
oh oh i've never got to that i've never
gone that's what i would want what
because because right i hate i don't
know why does it matter what your box is
this is literally [ __ ] american
psycho [ __ ] you know you're like you
open the drawer all the socks look the
same all the boxes i want the same open
account
so right now i'm sure you experienced
this right i have like i want to say
four different types of boxes okay right
so this is just i
picked them up or maybe i bought another
pair but it was different
and like i in my head i have like a soft
ranking of like which ones are the most
comfortable which one i'll go for you
know okay do you have this were you like
you know which pair of boxers you'd like
to wear the most i that's
surely there's going to be like one
because because in my head if they're
not comfortable then i'm just going to
no no no no no i'm not saying okay
maybe one of the pairs are not that
comfortable i should throw them out yeah
but the other three are all comfortable
but certain ones are more more
comfortable more luxurious maybe well
yeah maybe maybe because they're newer
yeah the newer ones are more comfortable
so it comes in terms of the time you've
spent using the box yeah well i i have a
pair of boxes that i got from one of our
sponsors ages ago and they're by far my
favorite ones yeah and i only have two
of them because we got them for free and
i don't want to buy any more so i'd
rather just replace them because they're
really nice
yeah they're really nice and i'm like ah
i like these a lot and these ones are
great and they like when i'm sweaty if
i'm doing sports something they're good
as well they wash really easily and i've
washed them like a billion times and
they're great so i i want to wear those
ones but then i'm like man should i just
get rid of all of them
but that feels so wasteful but i want to
get them more uniform and it's even
worse with socks bro my socks game is
wilding yeah i have like eight different
types of [ __ ] socks and they're all
different textures and thickness and it
is a nightmare but you need that
depending on the environment the mother
no i want uniform see that's why i did
the big brain move i replaced all my
stocks with family mart socks because
now you won't know if they're mismatched
at all the only other socks that i want
are like let's say i'm going
snowboarding or skiing i have a pair but
they're not in they're not they don't
think they don't get to mix yeah
yeah the daily socks are in their own
drawer and they're it's a it's a [ __ ]
mess i've got like literally eight
different [ __ ] textures going on
three of the textures i'm not a big fan
of yeah i should just purge it all i
should get rid of them all and just get
okay at which point do you look at a
pair of boxes and you go i think it's
time to throw these up because yeah
because like some people like because
some people will be like oh if there's
like a hole in it or like some people
would be like oh you know the hole's
only small and you know it's not like
if there's a hole in there you better
get [ __ ] rid of it guys that's right
that's a bit too fast because i used to
i used to be like the guy where it's
like if the hole is like small enough
where it's you know not going to get in
the way of being like uncomfortable then
it's like that's maybe got a couple more
months in it so like you know i didn't
want to be wasteful about it yeah for
one time
i was i got out of the shower and i was
like rummaging through my my my boxes
and i picked one up it looked fine on
the front and then i flipped it around
and right on the arse there was just
this giant hole
like a perfectly round hole and i was
like
you put your foot in and then you're
like you put your foot in the sock and
as you're about to like get to the end
you're like oh
my foot is out of the socket yeah you're
like oh like my big toe is all the way
out yeah